we're going to introduce our next
speaker
many of us know the smithsonian
but
other than artifacts and a wonderful
museum we may not know about the
research they do i had no idea our next
speaker dr sarah zappico is a researcher
there as well as having a day job as it
were as the assistant professor at the
department of chemistry and
environmental sciences at the new jersey
institute of technology her research
interests focus on the application of
biochemical techniques
to forensic science issues like age at
death estimation and the determination
of post-mortem interval with
implications in aging and biomedical
research
fascinating it looks it sounds like i'm
going to watch an episode of ncis sarah
then symposium audience is waiting for
more on your topic thank you
okay thank you very much for this
opportunity and introduction
let me share my screen
can you see
we can share your screen you might want
to go to presentation mode in your
slideshow menu
now yes it's fine there you go yep
okay good
so first of all uh
yes i am working in forensic science but
uh my phd actually was in biomedical
science in cancer research
but i always wanted to be a forensic
scientist so i changed during my postdoc
at smithsonian institution
uh because i what i did and i am doing
right now is translate what i learned
during my phd two forensic science
issues so i am going to
go over the different issues we have
there are more but where we could we can
introduce integrated omics technologies
so here we have a crime scene that you
can
watch for example on ncis
and one of the main things
will be identification
of the perpetrator from evidence of the
currency or sometimes the victim which
is mainly what i do
i am not sure how familiar you are
with identification in forensic science
but we are using what is called in
nuclear dna length polymorphisms
these are repetitions of four to six
nucleotides are called short thunder
repeats and these ones are normally in
intros or intragenic spacers
between games
and the number of repetition in its
shorthanded rabbits str
body between people
and the combination of these number of
repetitions in its str gives us the dna
profile that i will show you in the next
slide
actually right now the fbi has selected
20 core str lost site that must be run
in all dna tests in order to provide a
common currency with dna profiles to
upload in the database that maybe you
saw on tvs one
so this is another 20 actually but this
is an example of an str profile what you
see with the peaks here are the number
of repetitions and
in the top
the sdr
here for example the 21s 11 this person
is heterozygous
with 32 repetitions in one chromosome
and in the other one 38
here th01 you see is only one peak
because this person is homozygous 11 11.
and also we check the
sex
through the melody
x y means
but
what happens in these situations because
what i show you is normally what
you also would on tv the perfect profile
but it's not as easy so many times we
have mixed stores moreover in rake rate
cases
also in mass disaster scenarios we can
have degraded dna and partial profiles
and is when genomics uh in this case
massive parallel sequence plays a key
role uh first of all i put here the
forensic dna signature prep kit from
perugian because it's the one approved
by the api to upload in the database
so still
this kit what it does is to analyze 27
global autosomal sdrs also ystr which
are from the male chromosome as you know
but are from the
for example in cases of in bright cases
etc and extras
from the female
that's the coverage that i show you uh
in the bottom is possible to a better uh
resolution in challenging samples for
example the greatest samples and
increase the resolution for mixed stores
and although sometimes it's still
difficult
but still
the application of genomics in this case
to forensic science could help in these
challenging situations
but
we always need a reference sample
so something to compare it doesn't
matter if we have the profile from the
crime scene or the big thing
if we don't have something to compare
uh a reference example from the victim
or a reference sample from a possible
suspect
in this case we can think about what is
called forensic dna phenotype
this means it means infer the sample
donors estimate a disabled
characteristics eye color hair color
skin color from dna from the biological
material at the crime scene or from the
unknown bodies also we can include here
ancestry and h
in this case
we use snips single nucleotide
polymorphisms as you can see from the
picture is are changes in only one base
and the combination these changes
are giving us the
different colors the eye color the hair
color the skin color and the ancestry
here you have a
comparison between strs and snips
and maybe you think if it will be
possible also to identify a person using
snips only yes and as you can see here
we have the identity snips
but
you require more snips identity snips to
be able to provide an identification
and also yes phenotype snips
and ancestors
so going back to the uh to this kit uh
this has two separate uh
i would say kids
inside of the kit so the first one is
the one i told you before with the sdrs
the second one is this one with the
n94 identity snips
22 phenotyping snips for hair color
earth
skin color and 56 biogeographical
ancestry and here in the picture is the
result of the software
but
with this you have to be careful because
phenotyping and ancestry analysis are
not allowed in some of the states so
moreover in cases that you are looking
for the perpetrator because snips in
this case phenotyping and
biogeographical ancestry constitutes
identifiable information
if you realize when i talk about strs
strs are in introns or intragenic spaces
so this one you don't have the
information doesn't have any meaning but
this one does so for the reason uh
in some places some states it's really
difficult to use this uh for example for
identification of the perpetrator not
as much for trying to identify the
victim
and the other trend right now that you i
ensure her a lot
is the lineage snips
and presenting forensic genetic
genealogy
this is based on the uh looking for
identical by descendant snips so the
snips we share with our ancestors like
here in this
family tree
and here you have a table with the
relations um between the parents etc
and how does it work so when you do one
of these
tests period to consumer data tests to
dtma ancestry etc now you have the
option to decide if your data can be
stored in the database or not
if this data is stored in the database
get matched or familiar dna then
the forensic analogies are able to
access this data and go
try to for example from an evidence of
the crime scene
to see if
you or or whoever has a relation with
the perpetrator for example from the
crime scene
and these are the different um
i would say kids or microarrays
depending on the type of um
kit depending on the yeah on the table
kit you see uh
they are overlapping
uh some of them have more snips than
others but at the end
they do almost the same but looking into
different things
and this is the workflow uh
basically uh when the investigator has a
cold case because i am sure you've heard
right now a lot of cold cases are solved
thanks to policy and genealogy so they
have also to request permission to use
the evidence from the crime scene
for
foreign
then depending on how the things are
there are some labs that they do the
whole thing
analyze the snips and then
do the genetic genealogy or others they
simply send to the labs
to analyze testing and analyze the snips
and send to the genetic analogy so they
do the microarray for the snips or a
whole genome sequencing and then they
send to the genealogies to do the
kinetic
genealogy analysis
and based on that then they can follow
the uh trait to see if this aspect could
be related to someone in the
in the database
but again we have another problem here
because forensic kinetic genealogy as
forensic dna phenotyping provides
investigative leads
to currently identify the victim or the
perpetrator at the end it requires str
analysis and comparison so
it doesn't matter that you have this in
the kinetic genealogy at the end you
need to compare the suspect str profile
with this profile from the crime scene
so again we have another legal
issue here
i i include this one here because uh we
actually use for uh in some cases mostly
degrading and difficult samples is the
analysis of mitochondrial dna
uh the only problem it has is inherited
from the mother so uh the
all the relatives from the maternal
limits they have the same mitochondrial
dna it's not unique because you can i
would say share a share but cannot have
the same mutations as other person
and here what we analyze normally is
the
the control region which is a
hp1 hp2 and hp3
so you compare these uh
the mutations of these regions using
normal standard sequence with a
what is called a revised cambridge
reference sequence and then you compare
and know the mutations with these
mutations you determine the
mitochondrial output
where this i would say this person comes
from from the maternal units
so
there is here another this is also from
bayern deluge
some labs also are using is a the
forensic and mitochondrial dna control
regime and whole genome kit so they have
to again two options you can only
analyze other region but the problem is
if the person doesn't have enough
mutations in the control region uh it's
better to
to get the whole the
mitochondrial upper group to get the
whole
genome
and this is an example of the results
from one of the kids
and also this is the validation you can
see
that they more or less get the same
mutations
from the control region and the whole
genome kit
and
we normally use this for this kind of
samples that i told you uh they really
samples difficult samples like like bone
teeth a hair with a root although now
it's possible to get nuclear dna from
her with a root but before it was more
difficult so normally
you get mitochondrial dna fingerprints
for example because they don't have so
much dna and
remains or archaeological samples
so here we cover the genomics and
including dna profile phenotyping and
genius
going back to our crime scene
the other question is how long ago the
person died and although on tv maybe uh
yusto is easy
actually it's more on one of the most
challenging things in forensics so
uh maybe you are familiar with the terms
rigor mortis evo
these are good
but for the termination of post-mortem
interval or pmi
but
the main problem they are good for the
first
days of that
and after that is more difficult to
determine the pmi
and also you can think about insert
activity but also has some disadvantage
and all signal is not the same a corpse
tying or decomposing here in new year's
eve for example in maya
so
one of the things to improve that is
what we call sanitobiology
is the use of advances based on dna rna
and protein research for pmi estimation
and this is based on at the beginning
the cells go to autolysis
but the cell nucleus remains in that
four days after that
so we can apply cell biology methods for
pmi estimation
and here we are talking first about
transcriptomics
and i would like to show you this uh
study from
my group
we analyzed the post-mortem interval in
rat muscle
um
but using actually rna expression of
different
different
genes from autophagy and
apotoxy signal
what we realized was there is a switch
in signaling in the first hours of the
at the beginning there is an autophagy
signaling
because the cells are going to die by
but try to mitigate the stress
but at the end around four or six
hours after that there is uh
the triggering of the apoptosis
signaling
creating the extrinsic and intrinsic
pathway
and then releasing oxidative esters and
other components that could try to
mitigate that
so this was really interesting uh
because of the switching signals so when
i was actually a student for
a pump time biotech uh i did uh as a
final project i did
this a small study with
previous data from pratt retina and if
you are interested in the whole study is
in the youtube channel application of
transcriptomics amateur machine learning
to post multimeter estimation and here i
would like to show you the work and
plots that we
developed so you can see how
from the beginning of the day
there are there are kind of changes in
the expression of the different games
until the end uh 24 hours
is
up to uh where they get sampled you see
more uh genes are expressed
and
what
i really like because uh is uh
is related to my previous research is
that when we analyze the pathways
affected and here you can see apoptosis
pathways some
genes were overexpressed and others
don't express so as you can see this one
more or less confirm our previous
research
so we talked about transmitomics and now
the next one and also one of the things
right now is proteomics analysis of
protein abundance
in postmode
there are more studies but this one is
more or less recent and also following
with the mouse rat
mouse
station you can see how
these are different animals i will say
but
they have similar
outcomes in terms of proteomics and also
some of the proteins overlap as you can
see in in the beef
and in fact they identify two proteins
that decrease with the postmortem
interval in both
animals jpd8s and
eef1a2
so this can be useful for analyzing the
post-mortem interval in this case
so yeah we have the
proteome and then another trend is the
metabolomics analysis of metabolites as
a consequence of the decomposition
process
and here i would like to show you this
is from 2020 but i think it's really
interesting because here they could do
uh the study with human subjects uh
without killing anybody they did at the
texas state university uh forensic
entrepreneur research facilities so
about in donations
and compare with the rats and as you can
see in the top you have two human
subjects over time
you can see how there is an increase in
these metabolites cyanotine are amino
acids other are
decompositional by products and also in
rats you see
mostly
amino acids
free amino acids
so it could be useful in both
rats and human subjects for pmi
so here
we saw that proteomics and metabolomics
can help for pmi estimation
the other uh approach for pmi estimation
is the analysis of sanatorium microbial
and this fits
very well with the previous talk because
this is related to the analysis of
changes in bacterial communities as a
consequence of the decomposition process
so analysis here applying metagenomics
and here i would like to show you uh two
studies from my colleague dr joe at
series
uh she
did also these studies with human bodies
from the
forensic anthropology research facility
at the university of tennessee knoxville
and in this first study she analyzed how
the soil microbial change
with a data composition of the of the
courses and as you can see in the three
subjects in this case called three
donors
there
you can see the same pattern at the
beginning there are uh proteobacteria
from
bacterial heat
and others at the end mostly is
proteobacteria and feminine foods in the
three of them with variability because
obviously there is some variability on
the subject but still
you see the trend
but also what is really amazing is that
in the second study she analyzed the
oral microbiome of the corpses so see
how these chains uh with the pmi
and you can see more or less the same
thing in the three donors but also you
see at the end the most common er taxa
or fila is the
and phenical test so this uh these are
really interesting uh studies because
also we can apply
uh micro microbial microbial
analysis to uh determination of the pmi
and in fact dr serious and i
are going next week to the forensic
anthropology research facility at
western arena university to continue
with this research and the transatomic
research
so here we talk about uh metagenomics
for pmi estimates estimation
i'm going back to our crime scene and
although i said this here it will be one
of the first thing you try to do at
crime scenes is identification of body
fluids although you think
it could be easy
it's not standardized because what it
looks like to be blood it could be
ketchup for
example so in terms of in this case
people approach these with proteomics
analysis there are different techniques
maybe malditov or qtov
and is based on the identification of
proteins or combination of proteins
characteristics of the body fluid
however it's difficult to translate to
the field because normally when we go to
a crime scene
we try to detect body fluids using
alternative light sources and then when
you identify them
you analyze onsite
sometimes it not be sent to the lab
with for example rapid
immunochromatographic tests which are
similar to the copy therapy test that we
use right now so these are similar for
blood semen saliva etc
however this proteomics analysis
could be a conflamatory test for body
fluid
identification and here you have a
summary of the different um
different proteins
analyzing in the different main body
fluids that you find at the crime scene
but i would like to show you like two
examples this one they did with malditov
as you can see they didn't analyze the
whole uh
spectra as previously but you see the
difference in the pattern between
seminar genie which is a
protein from semen
versus alfamilase which is from saliva
you can see the
the pattern in the in each one in the
mass step
in this other study
you can see also the different proteins
and the relative intensity or relative
abundance
and in this case the authors also they
analyze
so
pass through the
qt of
samples from crime scene so evident
samples and even uh
the what they analyze the different
proteins
much er well with the
with the polyfruit for example semen and
also
different substrates cotton leather so
even
with that
having the body fluid in a substrate
it doesn't matter because you can still
identify the body
here we can include in the proteomics
metabolomics
the body fluid identification
so in conclusion omix technologies can
help to solve current issues in forensic
science like identification of
challenging samples and improving
post-mortem interval estimation among
others
but omix approaches are slowly
integrated into the forensic field to a
two legal limitations as i described at
the beginning
photo research will be able to expand
this current studies hopefully leading
to a wider implementation of comics
technologies
and as i told you from our part we are
going to continue with research in
transcriptomics and microbial
as i told you
with dr yo series
i haven't talked about epi genetics but
i am using epigenetics for age
estimation
from
teeth
but the integration of a next-generation
sequencing technologies in this case is
slowly as well
and also is using epigenetics for body
fluid identification also another thing
i didn't mention but is also still on
the works
and microbial forensics for human
identification and body fluid
identification so here we need to
include this
epigenetic
metagenomics
and uh i would like to thank er first uh
you all for
listening uh all the people involved in
the postmortem interval uh project also
fun time bio for the invitational also
for their house during the uh the course
i was doing um yeah uh one thing uh i am
hiring er we are looking for a postal
biology is biochemist bioinformatics
someone who knows how to work with this
data it doesn't need to be a
bioinformatics but
uh yeah
and also if you're interested in these
topics
thank you you have any questions i will
be happy to answer now or later you can
send me an email thank you
thank you sarah forensics is such a
captivating field you know we see it in
tv like i said in movies and yet so much
more i appreciate your time and
knowledge for sharing with us we do have
a couple questions for you in our time
that we've got left so feel free to
expand how do forensic sciences benefit
from the omics technologies
so in general for example uh at the
beginning when i talk about genomics
in this case
because of the coverage of the olympics
uh technologies
is uh
obviously is easier or more like uh
yeah it covers more in terms of more for
example the greedy samples so
the problem
when we try to um amplify the sdrs in in
general
is that sometimes the primers are really
out of not out but are not
closer enough
in the region so in the greatest samples
is one of the
problems that you have so with the
coverage of the omix technologies
in genomics in this case it's possible
to cover these regions several times
analyze several times and try to be more
precise and getting better profiles for
example and then in postmortem interval
estimation in this case
in general transcriptomics proteomics et
cetera will help us
the
different studies described
in improving their estimations
fascinating so what are the skills
required to establish a career in this
field
uh in forensic okay
these are different skills i mean
depending also on what you know it's
funny because you know i am coming from
biomedical science i mean i am
biologists and biochemists
in spain i am originally from spain uh
in spain we all have so much in
forensics so i did my best in biomedical
sciences
still i could change so i did a master's
in foreign genetics at the university of
granada
and i changed my postdoc to forensic
science so
i think the most important thing is uh
you are
interested in this field uh you are
willing to learn and you have an open
mind
you know there are a lot of legal
limitations influences as i describe but
i ensure doing research will help
with so many things for example
identification of human remains so
basically
yes
if you are interested in dna i mean
biology biochemistry
yes it's basically these are the species
you gotta you're gonna have to know a
lot of that i'm getting from all the
speakers that it's just not you gotta
just go know this you've gotta gotta
know a whole bunch of stuff right yeah
yeah
yeah so i'm gonna i'm gonna come back to
real questions i've got a question my
own when are we going to see you on tv
so what are the current omics
technologies used for data from forensic
science
so
assuming
in real forensic cases
it means because in forensic cases i
know for a fact that
some people are using the
i i mean very game is not paying me for
saying that but it's because if they
want approved by the fbi i know some
forensic labs they use the uh
veteran kit the forensic signature kit
um also orders
the strs
others use them
the mitochondrial dna for sure
and
also
because it's one of the things you heard
a lot defensive genealogy
so
applicable to forensic cases
then in research we are using
all the
all the techniques that i show you today
so one thing is research but in terms of
currency cases
people are using the the omics the
genomics foreign
then the foreign genealogy
okay
how did you get interested in this what
made you switch to this field
uh actually i wanted to be a forensic
scientist since i was a child
but again
the problem uh
was in spain there were not so many
opportunities uh so
yeah i got my phd i mean
i am grateful for the uh time during my
phd i learned a lot and in fact what you
saw today uh related to the post-mortem
interval the
uh rna expression analysis was because
of what what i was doing during my phd
but i really want i know is that and
also some people will tell you that yeah
the funding in forensic is not great
but still i think you are helping people
so i think this is the most important
thing
for me
thank you so much we really appreciate
your time here i think at least i think
everybody's fascinated because of all
the tv shows and movies but um
it's still fascinating that all that can
be determined in that way so we really
appreciate your time here sarah thank
you for being on the
symposium and we'll bring you back here
in a few minutes for the panel at the
end so stick around we'll be right back
to you thank you thank you so much thank
you you're welcome